[Music]
this is star talk neil degrasse tyson
here your personal astrophysicist and
today it's a cosmic aquarius edition on
climate change and what nasa has to say
about it
and what nasa might
be doing about it and we've got here
chuck nice check
hey neil you know you you you you you
think a lot about climate change i've
seen you do some philanthropic
activities in this in this place i
devote a lot of my time to uh uh trying
to educate people through entertainment
and other means about the climate crisis
okay i call it that because it is
because sometimes you got to make them
laugh to have them listen i guess is
that yeah you know that's how that's how
i've stayed married all these years
yeah so i so while whatever you know and
i know about climate is not the level of
expertise we require to have a show
based on that subject and so we combed
the landscape and we said oh yeah
the recently appointed nasa chief
scientist
is also the nasa's senior climate
advisor what do you think of that what
and we've got her on star talk now
catherine calvin kate welcome to star
talk
thanks and thanks for having me i'm
really excited to be here so if my notes
are correct here you've been an earth
scientist at the pacific northwest
national laboratories joint global
change
research institute did i say all that
right
you did it's a lot of words but yes and
i've been there i was there from 2008
until the beginning of this year okay i
don't know if anyone told you but it's
got pacific northwest in it but it's
based in college park maryland did
someone make a mistake there did i did i
or did i
and by the way they need a long they
need a longer title
oh for sure there definitely could be
some more words in there um no it is so
the pacific northwest national lab is
headquartered in washington state but
they have a small group based out of
maryland on the university of maryland's
campus oh gotcha gotcha that's where you
were okay so that's how that's a a good
explanation for this okay but your
research focuses on climate change but
especially
where
the human
civilization
influence it and is impacted by it is
that a fair characterization of your
professional profile that's correct i
was looking at how human activities
cause climate change and what climate
change does to human activities
that's quite a that's quite a a do loop
there okay
it's a nice little feedback loop
all right so so remind us all what just
nasa chief scientist does because nasa
has a lot of scientists but to be chief
scientists what does that mean
so my job as chief scientist is to
integrate science across nasa to
represent that
that science externally including with
other agencies uh international partners
uh the public people like you um and i
also provide advice to the administrator
on on science administrators
the head person of nasa oh okay the
administrator right
right right and so
okay and so now is this the first time
that chief scientist has been a climate
scientist because i've known many a
chief scientist and and you know
many all the ones i've known have been
astrophysicists or or planetary
scientist is this the first time
no there was an earth scientist who um
research was on the cryosphere a while
ago so i'm not the first climate related
person in this role you know i only just
learned the meaning of the word
cryosphere that's the ass word chuck do
you remember what it means uh it means
everything frozen anywhere about
anything
at any time
including iced tea
ice cube
vanilla
it's all in the cryosphere yeah i love i
love that word i love it so this is a
cosmic queries edition and we've
collected questions from our most loyal
fan base our patreon members and chuck
you've got them you got all the
questions got them right here on the
trusty tablet let's do it so we might as
well let's uh let's jump right into this
with mason
mason says mason didn't even give you
his last name because he didn't want you
to try to pronounce it i think his last
name is jar
so
okay
god what a dad joke that was that was so
that was that was so
that's right like yeah
so that's legit it's legit if you
actually are a dad if you are a dad
right
i actually heard my children just go man
stop
stop it bro okay here we go uh
what are nasa's plans to combat climate
change are there any long-term
short-term plans in regards to the
rising levels of greenhouse gas
emissions
i've read interesting things on huge
towers filled with moss plants that
could help filter the air is this
something nasa may be helping with
wow
look at that yeah so i think so kate
isn't this
on the scale of geoengineering i mean
it's a whole other concept there
so other than give us data about
what we're doing bad
and possibly advising on what we should
be doing what is in the power of nasa to
actually fix this yeah that's a great
question so nasa first of all we observe
the earth from space so we can provide
data that helps inform decisions about
climate change and we've been doing this
for decades so we have a long array of
data about things like vegetation or
carbon dioxide or temperature to see how
earth is changing in terms of how to
reduce and to mitigate climate change
nasa has two roles in this one is we do
climate modeling so we can understand
what the effects are of different
emission scenarios in the future
the second is we actually develop
technologies that can help mitigate and
adapt to climate change so we have a
sustainable aviation program that has
been working on reducing fuel use and
emissions from airplanes making them
more more efficient in all ways i guess
dynamically as well as their engines and
and i just got to i just got to
interject there correct me from wrong
kate
but your climate group in nasa is based
in new york city is that yes
the climate modeling group is based in
new york city at the goddard institute
for space studies oh god it's do for
space studies and they they are over
the restaurant
that's featured in seinfeld
the building that houses that restaurant
contains the goddardness
am i correct about that kate yes you are
all right what's the deal with climates
who are these people
so
so um so this isn't this is encouraging
but how about these concepts of like
moss towers or or carbon dioxide
scrubbers out of the atmosphere is this
still science fiction
well i think when you talk about
removing carbon from the atmosphere
there are a number of different
techniques in there the most common one
would be planting a tree uh and so
planting what a concept
we've been doing it for a while
but yeah trees take carbon out of the
atmosphere um and that is one way of
reducing carbon i think nasa's role in
this is really on observation so we can
actually look at the trees and measure
how many trees we have how how they
change over time we also measure carbon
dioxide so we can monitor how that
changes over time
so a biological question since you
brought up trees
is a tree the most effective
plant that can
remove carbon is there something that we
could be planting in addition to or
other than trees that would actually
pull out more carbon good question
that's a it's a good question it's a
complex question because it depends on
the type of tree where you're planting
it what was there before and so the
effect of a planting of a tree on carbon
depends on a lot of factors
trees also change the way the earth's
surface reflects energy so where you
plant those could also have an effect
not just from their carbon removal so
isn't it true that it's it's not good
enough to only think about the carbon
dioxide in our atmosphere because the
ocean has something to say about this
doesn't it
yeah that's important so the ocean
absorbs quite a bit of carbon so when we
emit carbon into the um some of it goes
into the ocean some goes into the land
and some stays in the atmosphere
oceans also uptake heat and so they play
a really important role in climate
change both today and how that changes
in the future and so the more we can
understand the oceans the more we
understand climate but if i pull co2 by
whatever magic way out of the air
the ocean says oh wait i can give you
more co2 isn't that right
well there is a balance in that so when
you take can you move carbon from one
pool to the other the others will
respond until they reach an equilibrium
okay oh
yeah wow
okay look at that so you can take take
it out of the air and uh and
and the ocean said here's some more
you're not getting away that easily
you put it in here to begin with i'm
just giving it back to you i think
that's that's that dialogue right right
all right so chuck what else you got all
right let's uh
let's move on to
sarah perry
sarah perry says this hello star talk
climate change has been a huge
discussion for a while now and i keep
hearing scientists and politicians say
that we're approaching a point of no
return
i don't know why i said that like
william shatner i don't know
a point of no return anyway
uh we need to act now is what they say
my question is what exactly is the point
of no return are we actually close to
the point of no return and what is close
anyways what is the tipping point for a
major climate change and how much time
would that tipping point tape to
completely change our atmosphere
and our weather
so
yeah what's up with tipping points kate
i'm detecting a very distinct
uh uh skepticism
sarah perry's question no i get a total
apocalyptic uh state of concern there i
read that differently it's like is it a
tippy point are we there yet when is it
going to happen what can i do about it
because it has a kind of manic flavor
yeah the broccoli
all right what you got kate well i think
what's important to know is that we're
already experiencing the effects of
climate change now so the planet has
warmed and along with that we're seeing
heat extremes we're seeing increases in
wildfire
we're seeing changes in our wat and
precipitation and in water cycles and
scientists what the science shows is
that as warming continues those will
increase
so we will see more
changes in temperature more heat
extremes more an increase in the um in
the proportion of intense tropical
cyclones uh more wildfire weather and so
we'll see more and more of that as
temperatures rise
so so you're not thinking of it as a
tipping point as much as we're just
entering the gates of hell and
systematically and and
but i think the tipping point implied
that no matter what we do we'll never
reverse it
right and there are some parts of
climate that are irreversible so things
like ice sheet melt and sea level rise
once once an ice sheet melts it's
irreversible on the time scales that
we're typically talking about so it can
take centuries to millennia there are
other impacts though like the heat
extremes that are reversible if you can
bring global mean temperature back down
you would reduce the heat extreme again
but it depends on the impact whether
it's reversible or not okay i hadn't
thought about that there's a difference
there because if you melt ice you're not
remaking that ice because we're not in
an ice age right exactly so you raise
the water level that you're stuck with
that but everything else maybe we can
get a handle on okay what if we got
10 million battery operated
refrigerators
with ice makers
that would work chuck i'm sure yes okay
i would need to do some more math
on that chuck before you bring that to
the table
it just pumps out the ice cube it's just
shooting out ice cubes
in the beijing olympics that those
mountains didn't have any snow on it
let's bring in some snow and some ice
making some snow makers so yeah all
right all right all right well sarah
there you go wait but but but chuck you
got to remember and there's no free ride
in the world of thermodynamics so what
you needed energy to make the ice that
your refrigerator was punching out the
back door right so even battery operated
or solar powered oh solar if your solar
would work
okay so
yeah so
you put them where there's very little
sun which is in the polar regions
there
here's what you're saying what
think this through
go ahead i think you need some research
yeah do a little a little more research
on it right yeah make that your
dissertation chuck
if we squeeze one more in before we take
our first break all right here we go
uh hello neil
what is keeping nuclear energy
from being the mainstream when it's
clearly a better scalable option than
most of renewable energies that we are
currently using
nukes very very cool
all right
we're going to
pick that up after the break
what role do nukes play in our future
of climate change how about that okay
and you got you'll be ready for that one
when we come back kate
uh
not a direct answer but an answer
[Music]
we'll have an answer for you from kate
from nasa when star talk returns
we're back on star talk
cosmic queries we're talking about
climate change and nasa with nasa's
chief scientist
katherine calvin catherine uh great to
have you um in your academic
pedigree um what did you do your phd on
my phd is in a department called
management science and engineering but
it was really applied math so i was
looking at i learned how to develop
mathematical models to do things like
optimization
and understand how to write a computer
program using math to describe a system
so this is something i think we don't
have enough of in this world today
because everyone you know you go through
the stove pipe field i'm the expert in
this one thing and somebody else is an
expert in some other thing and no one
brings it all together when the whole
world actually operates
systemically right so so we need more of
you out there
when that was a lot of my last job so i
view math and computer science as sort
of a universal language if you can write
an equation you can write a computer
program then you can then link it to any
other kind of science and that was part
of what i was doing was linking physics
with ecology and econ economics and
hydrology
yeah it's not enough of that for sure
yeah so chuck we let we
we we last left off uh who asked this
question
so this is thiago
pereira pereira from portugal portuguese
nuclear
power as an alternative source of energy
to uh fossil fuels right possibly being
our savior
so so it's okay as a scientist but also
as a public servant how do you weigh
what the science tells you and what
people want
if what they want has a deep emotional
resistance to a solution
what i can say is in my role as chief
scientist and senior climate advisor and
similar to my role before my job is to
provide the science to inform that and
so the second part of that would be on
the on the purview of someone else but
what we science can tell you is what the
effects are of a particular option you
might be considering um on a variety of
different factors so how does it affect
emissions how does it affect something
else
and a lot of what the science i was
doing before was looking at was what if
scenarios so what if you do more of this
or less of that and what does that mean
and you model all this you you get to
model that yeah and we just provide
science-based information that others
can use to make decisions but if people
are spooked by chernobyl you're spooked
by fukushima
uh and old timers the hulk the hulk
radiation radio yeah
yeah if they have some sort of spook
they're spooked by that from from
decades past
if we know for example that modern power
plants are not that are not susceptible
to those problems
what do you do do you try to say look
folks warm up to this because that might
be our only solution or do you just take
a step back from that let the
politicians worry about it and still
just pump the science into the dialogue
well i think for me with my background
i'm not a nuclear engineer or a nuclear
expert and so in this i can only say
what the kind of research i was doing
was which was we would include it as a
portfolio of options and see
what happens in different what-if
scenarios
but i view the role of a scientist is to
provide an unbiased characterization of
any technology regardless of what it is
so this is what we know about it and try
to provide as much complete information
as we can um and very precise
information so this is how it affects
this or this is how it affects that so
that makes way too much sense that
you're just making too much sense here
yeah
remember
america we're talking about that yeah
who needs that
who needs your measured response about
what works and data empirical evidence
how do i feel about this kate that's all
that matters
right how do i tweet about it first of
all kate here's what i want to know
what about the children
no all right let me ask for real um
do any of your models actually give us
kind of are you asking this question or
is it a patreon no no no this is a
follow-up that thiago actually had you a
lion okay go on
[Laughter]
any of your models have a percentage
mixture of what energy sources are best
not best so again science can give you
information best is a qualitative word
right okay say optimal optimal
so what we can do is sort of look at
what if you wanted to do
you know limit warming to a particular
level what if you wanted to do this and
look at how what what worlds might be
consistent with that um
so so when you say what if you're
talking about if you want this outcome
this much carbon must be
you know reduced and these are the ways
that you could do it is that what you're
saying
right so what some of the some of the
reports on this that are really thorough
or from the intergovernmental panel on
climate change um and so they that's
where i would go if i was looking up
something new in climate um and what
they have looked at is if you you know
future warming depends on future
emissions and they can look at you know
how much can you emit of carbon dioxide
and stay within a particular warming
level and then they provide some example
pathways that are consistent with that
and those pathways would show you you
know what sorts of emissions reductions
would you need to do in order to get to
a particular level but it's very much
what if if you want to limit warming to
a particular level what is consistent
with that and what can the science tell
you about that that just makes so much
sense it does we need more of this kind
of thinking in government for sure
in other words we're doomed
in case the only one talking this
way we need more rational evidence-based
thinking oh brother
all right chuck what else you got all
right here we go uh here we go this is
jonathan brown jonathan says hello dr
calvin hello dr neal and hello
okay never mind i'm not
it was like yeah hello chuck yeah
really
okay
could you please discuss natural climate
change that may take place over
thousands of years on earth and how
humanity directly accelerates or alters
this process i think one of the main
arguments for climate change skeptics is
that they think it's solely a natural
process or cycle that has occurred and
will continue to occur over time on
earth and maybe that's true or maybe
it's not i just before you speak your
kate i will not elevate
their comments to the level of
skepticism it's a level of ignorance
okay
don't confuse skepticism with abject
ignorance okay of how things work okay
take it
so there are natural changes in climate
some of them are very long-term some of
them are short like el nino la nina um
but what we see in the most last 150
years is an unprecedented rate of change
and when the scientists have looked into
what's causing that it's attributable to
greenhouse gas emissions so the increase
in greenhouse gas emissions since the 18
late 1800s has led to this change in
climate and we can see this through a
number of different ways
we have laboratory studies that show
that increases in concentrations of
greenhouse gases trap heat we can learn
from other planets about what happens
when you have more greenhouse gas
emissions in the atmosphere we can also
learn from models about what happens
there but what we see in the last 150
years is unprecedented and the science
has attributed it to human activity
i heard something interesting kate that
if there is a silver lining
if there is a silver lining
what we're doing now to the climate will
delay
the next ice age
silence
let me just say
um
alex i'll take what the hell for 500.
the spirit of alex okay exactly
i mean
temperatures are going up now rather
than down but i think what's um what's
challenging is that the rate of change
that's happening so we're experiencing
these impacts and we're experiencing
them at a very quick pace compared to
natural climate cycles and that makes it
harder for ecosystems and people to
adapt
okay
well i can tell you if we do enter
another ice age whenever that is the
water evaporates from the oceans and it
snows onto the land and then it just
stays there because it never melts and
you'll systematically drain the water
levels of the world creating new
oceanfront real estate
well you you know you sound like a super
villain right
lex luthor
[Laughter]
so chuck next question
all right here we go uh
hmm
all right jeff johnson
jeff johnson wants to know this are you
picking names that are easy to read of
course i am over okay yeah lie about
your name or just give me some initials
people
no
go no jeff johnson actually did write in
and he said hey there's a lot of talk
about terraforming
venus or mars
but i am curious
what are we doing if anything to
terraform our own planet does this fall
under the realm of climate change
initiatives quite a lot of our planet is
desert or other harsh land types
should we consider
terraforming
these places on our own planet
another if i can add to that question
kate sure do deserts serve any role in
the world
do they like you know i don't think much
of anything lives there
right if we terraformed our desert
wouldn't that be beneficial to everybody
to humans as well as creatures and and
vegetation
so i think all parts of the earth system
play an important role in in the world
that we're living in now and anything
that you change you need to carefully
consider what the effects might be and
that's one of the things that we do in
climate science is try to understand
these effects
a lot of there's a lot of concern around
desertification and land degradation so
that as you change as precipitation
cycles change as you impact the earth it
affects the terrestrial system there's
also you know deforestation or
aforestation that changes
the earth's surface and um how much
vegetation that you have and what the
world looks like
so air force station means you had a
forest over here but now it's over there
adding trees um so adding more
trees okay
and you could simultaneously deforest in
a forest in theory but we look at it as
they're separate processes one you have
fewer trees one you have more
but essentially as scientists what we
look at is what would the effects of
each of those things be
either using models or laboratory
experiments and then at nasa we observe
that from space so we can see how those
things change over time so with respect
to that and jeff's question
they're wiping out for us in the amazon
is there any data that lets you know
what that's going to do to the planet
and are the any models that say if we
continue here's what's going to happen
good sure so changing tree cover in
general affects carbon so trees store
carbon and if you cut them down you
change the amount of carbon that the
earth can absorb you also if you burn
them you release carbon into the
atmosphere and so you're changing the
amount of carbon dioxide which we know
carbon dioxide
leads to warming
the other thing that happens is you
change the reflectivity of the earth's
surface so trees um and you can change
water cycles so in high latitudes so in
the arctic if you cut down a tree and
then there's snow instead you're
changing how much energy the earth
reflects in low latitudes you change
water and so changing trees can affect
temperature both through changes in
carbon and through other factors and
have an effect on local warming and we
do study this we we measure it
and monitor it we do modeling based on
this to try to understand what's going
on now and what might happen in the
future okay it sounds like you have like
a hundred thousand million variables
right
from the reflectivity to the water
cycles to the oceans to the land to the
to the to the rate that you're making it
the rate that it's pulling back
how
isn't this just some beast
this multi-headed beast in your computer
that that how do you tame it how do you
have any control over that at all
in any kind of way that leaves you
confidence
that leaves you confident in what
results come out
and plus there's a term you haven't used
but i'm thinking you're dancing around
it and it's unintended consequences
right there's like if you do this yeah
like you like you said chuck if you cut
down the forest well we've modeled these
seven things is there an eighth thing
you hadn't thought about
that could change where the locusts land
or something and and then the scientists
end up getting the bad rap scientists
neglected to consider uh meanwhile we've
predicted everything else right um so
how do you how do you tame the beast
so first of all there's thousands of
scientists doing this so it's not one
person and they all approach the problem
from different disciplines so they can
think about different things
and then we break it down in models
we're writing mathematical equations and
computer programs and we can isolate
parts of that make sure we get that part
right before we link it to the next part
and this is where observations like the
ones that nasa collects is really
important both to initialize your model
to help parameterize your model and to
evaluate the model and so the models i
was working on before use data like what
we get from satellites to help um
develop them and evaluate them okay i
neglected to fully
consider that so whatever
however beastly the program is and all
the factors that it's considering you
look people look to nasa and say wait a
minute nasa has a data point that says
this is not as variable as we thought
that puts a constraint on that and i
have a limit on that on this other
variable and so this helps localize what
the beast can the damage the beast can
do it sounds like exactly so all the
observations that we collect help
constrain
the the models and um
and help us develop them going forward
and so we can break apart those pieces
and get confidence okay very cool
wow so okay all right chuck one more
question maybe we can slip it in before
we take our second and final break okay
mikhail
boise vert no boisvert boys vert
[Laughter]
he says hello dr tyson dr calvin lord
nice
we figure out how to solve the human
problem
could we slow down the melting of land
ice by
while we figure this out can we slow
down the melting of land eyes by one
sprinkling something on it to raise its
melting point
a quick search of terra uh
terra butley ammonium hydroxide
raises it to 86 degrees
fahrenheit all right also sounds like
you gave the earth cancer um
and then lowering its thermal
conductivity uh by scooping it up in a
machine that would expand it like an
aero gel
oh this is uh oh
bravia blah blah that's how you say his
name uh
boiver boiver it's michael blevir he
gave me the phonetic spelling at the end
that did thanks
that's okay this is again sounds like
it's from the category of geoengineering
and these are these are ideas that maybe
work on paper
but do you get to put in your models
these these sort of crazy future geo
injury geo engineering ideas to try to
help that out
i never specifically studied geo
engineering but there are people that do
and they try to understand them
and a lot of the ones that people talk
about are stratospheric aerosol
injection so reflecting the sunlight by
putting aerosols high up in the
atmosphere the high clouds yeah high
clouds
um but what you know as a scientist what
we're trying to do is understand what
that might mean and so what you see in
some of that you can reduce temperatures
from doing something like
stratospheric aerosol injection but
there's a lot of uncertainties and a lot
of risks and a lot of things we don't
know
and one thing in particular to think
about is that that doesn't do anything
you're you know if you're doing
something like that you're not reducing
carbon dioxide so something like ocean
acidification isn't going to be impacted
by that
interesting
all right we got one segment left we're
going to take a break and when we come
back we might go into lightning round
what do you think of that see we get
more of these questions out of because
we we just luxuriate on these answers
with all these questions we have so many
interested parties there so chuck why
don't you do a quick filter uh for this
break and when we come back more with dr
catherine calvin from nasa on star talk
we're back start talk third and final
segment
and we're at the cosmic queries and
we're talking about climate change and
nasa
climate change and nasa and we've got
the chief scientist of nasa dr catherine
calvin and kevin is there a best website
for people to track nasa's climate
activities
nasa has a climate website and includes
a a set of indicators for nasa climate
including things like what temperature
rises today compared to before see at
current co2 levels uh they have a lot
that's a geeky
yeah that's the kind of geeks love
oh yeah okay what what's what does that
handle
uh i think it's climate.nasa.gov
okay
if not just google climate and nasa and
you can yeah probably got a feeling it's
gonna come up it's gonna come away
all right chuck give me some more
questions all right and let's see if we
can do like a lightning round we'll put
we'll put kate on the spot uh pretend
like she can only answer in sound bites
and see how many questions we can get
through here okay all right all right
give it to um teresa anasky theresa says
hello dr tyson hello dr calvin uh lord
nice a huge
what a huge volcanic eruption throwing
an ungodly amount of particulate into
the upper atmosphere caused a temporary
cooling on the earth as it has in the
past for instance
krakota
krakatoa thank you thank you
yeah yeah so volcanoes do inject sulfur
into the atmosphere and in previous
really large volcanoes we see it in the
temperature record but it depends on the
amount of um of material coming out of
the volcano and how high it goes what
the effects are on climate
because you know we forget we just think
of the atmosphere as one monolithic
thing but if you're if you're if in your
head it's layers right in your in your
studies and so
particles at different layers have
different effects is what you're saying
right yeah i think a good example of
this would be something like ozone so in
the stratosphere ozone protects against
incoming uv
and on the surface ozone causes local
health effects
right right
so i got a feeling that the stuff coming
out of a volcano might also have
some local health effects
risk of vaporization yeah i'm just
saying
just saying maybe that's going to be a
bit of a problem just all right very
cool wait wait chuck you don't remember
the krakatoa movie uh krakatoa east of
java it was one of the disaster movies
from like the 1970s i have did not i do
not know that yeah krakatoa easter java
and and the problem was krakatoa is
actually west of jabba so i don't know
why they named the movie that way i
checked him on a map when i was a kid
that's when he ran
[Laughter]
all right keep it coming all right this
is uh
achilles uh kashyap who says
hello dr tyson dr calvin can you tell us
more about how
nissar nisa are
is different from other earth observing
satellites also will it be able to
contribute to
climate science
so kate what's different about that
satellite versus others
well it's really looking at how the the
surface moves and dynamics that are
happening on the earth's surface like
ice sheets dynamics and landslides
okay all right because that's that
matters right of course it does that
would matter all right all right cool
and did you remember what it stands for
n-i-s-a-r
that's always a test
um
you should make something we'll be good
with that
yeah i don't remember the exact action
okay all right we won't hold it against
you nobody ever remembers acronyms
so
all right chuck keep it coming all right
abhinav yadav
who says
i know he doesn't pronounce it that way
we're going i'm sure he doesn't either
to be honest like i'm looking at it and
it's just y-a-d-a-v
but it's probably pronounced like
johnson
it's it's because it's like
yeah
just
get a little
flavor in there okay
says wow you know what you did make it
sound better i got it i know i'm telling
you yeah
uh hello dr tyson hello dr calvin first
of all
congrats to you dr calvin
and secondly what options do we have now
to deal with climate change given the
most recent report
states smaller efforts
will have no impact
oh
[Music]
humans are interacting with the climate
climates interacting with humans is
there some threshold below which we're
not doing a damn thing
i'm not exactly sure um
there what we're what we're asking but
what i can say is that what we can look
at is how different levels of emissions
or emissions reductions or emissions
increases affect temperature um and
sketch that out i think one thing that's
really important to know is that know
there's other processes like el nino la
nino and so you might not see
you know temperature isn't smooth going
forward it hasn't been smooth in the
past and so there are levels where you
you might not notice temperature change
in the same way because of natural
variability
okay but in terms of
actions that i can take paper or plastic
you know you know uh electric or you
know there are little decisions i might
make in a day
tesla or hummer
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay
airplane or hang glider
i think people just want to know
is what they're doing having any effect
at all i think that's
at some point that's what people are
asking
and it's a great question i think what
science can tell you is what the
different options might mean
and there are people that track
emissions over time so you know we can
look at how things have changed in the
past
um and there are people that study what
the effect of individual technologies or
actions might be on emissions in the
future okay well let me just if i may uh
doctor uh because i know the report he's
talking about
and uh it speaks to
the inefficacy of individual action
creating enough of a significant change
but i will say that what individual
action does do
is it causes people to become engaged in
the issue itself
other forces end up operating exactly a
collective forces right a collective
force so it doesn't make a difference if
whether or not you recycle actually
makes a difference the fact that you're
recycling actually brings the issue to
your four
to the four and that may cause you to
take other actions as well okay that's
total a behavioral shift right exactly
right right yeah
and so katherine our crack team of
researchers uh looked up the the acronym
and oh my gosh okay this acronym
contains two letters that are themselves
the first letter of two other acronyms
okay awesome
so this is we got nested acronyms okay i
got it here right so
nissar is
nasa itself an acronym isro
and that's just the eye from the
nasa isro synthetic aperture radar
yep so the two agencies that are leading
the mission plus the technology plus the
technology look at that
very cool
that that's that's uh uh acronyms gone
gone wild it really is
all right keep it going show me more we
can get in we've got five minutes left
go for it uh all right here we go this
is dylan and i like dylan he's got one
name like cher uh dylan says hello dr uh
dr tyson hello dr calvin uh the great
and the great comedic co-host what
finally somebody actually is
complimentary okay
uh as someone who has to grow up with
this troubling issue i was wondering
what the future would be like if by some
magic all fossil fuels
were stopped burning
now
and we went to 100 percent renewable
energy today thank you all for what you
do
interesting oh that's awesome in your
model you could probably model that yeah
so all
it stops today and then what happens
next yeah so there was actually a study
on this um that was in the last couple
of years of looking at what if you
halted fossil fuel emissions today and
what you get is that essentially climate
will stay at the level it's at today and
so what we know though is that we're
already experiencing climate impact so
we would keep those levels of impacts
and what the science really says is that
future warming depends on future
emissions so more emissions in the
future more warming stopping emissions
you keep your current so if we stop
today we don't reverse what has happened
we just don't get worse
right to reverse climate change you
would need to take carbon out of the
atmosphere rather than stop putting it
in the atmosphere exactly
okay that's an important distinction and
very tightly answered there that's
almost that damn near sound bite for you
yeah okay all right all right here we go
keep it coming all right um
hello neil hello chuck hello catherine
villaletta here your 13 and a half year
old astrophysics kid writing from
washington dc with this question this is
the violetta this is d v a letter give
her a full name just so we get the full
the full
thrust here okay
via letter and mom izzy that's the
fullness
sorry mom yeah but you're right jordan's
got a way cooler name than you do oh man
i never thought of it that way violet
and izzy okay uh
here we go
she says to uh uh to dr calvin what is
your absolute
number one goal
in your role as nasa chief scientist
and how do you plan to achieve it
thank you for being a role model to
young women everywhere
wow cool okay yeah so i just think nasa
science is
nasa does amazing science i've been
involved with some of the climate work
before using it in the work i was doing
we also have all of this really cool
astrophysics and heliophysics and
planetary science and i just want to
make sure everyone knows what nasa's
doing
throughout the entire portfolio
wow okay so so because that would uh you
can't govern in clouds of ignorance so
nasa feeds information and data to those
who have the power to do something about
it with laws or legislation and the like
is that a fair characterization nasa
provides information that can help
decision makers at all levels um make
informed decisions so do they call you
in front of congress or do they call the
administrator in front of congress
i don't know the answer to that okay i
think they should call you in front of
congress yeah exactly vote for that
right now
all right here's the follow-up question
from violetta uh she's asking because of
her age how does one get appointed to be
nasa chief scientist anyway it sounds
like the coolest job ever i'm just
saying you might find yourself passing
the torch to me one day she's oh she's
out
oh man a couple of years ago it was oh
i'm being a letter and i have a simple
little question right now she's going to
take over the world exactly now she's
just like i'm taking down the cheap
scientists
and there's nothing you can do about it
yeah i will say i agree with her it's
the coolest job ever i get to learn
science every day i get to talk to
people about science and there's nothing
more fun than sort of seeing what
energizes a scientist and then trying to
capture that energy and explain it to
someone else um in terms of how how you
get here just keep asking questions and
keep learning
yeah and so so it's not like you lobbied
for that post you were just very visible
in your work and nasa goes around and
says there's somebody we could use like
right now in this seat i mean is that
basically how that happens
yeah so i think that they you know there
was a multi-stage interview process but
they were looking for someone that that
knew climate science and that could help
elevate nasa's climate science as well
as represent the rest of nasa science
and do you have to be approved by
congress by the senate no okay so you're
an appointee
by the head of the
uh of the agency
i'm serving in an intergovernmental
personnel act mobility program
okay
i don't know what the hell that is
okay i think it's like they built a set
of highways and freeways so they can
move expertise
simply and easily without what would
normally be the red tape however red
tapey that title sounds
yeah it's a way of doing temporary
assignment between the federal
government and other eligible entities
yeah very cool and it allows the federal
government to tap expertise that it
might not otherwise have access to
within its own circles exactly
right wow for a very bureaucratic
sounding name it's relatively efficient
yes it's a badass way to to get talent
where you need it when you have to have
it dr calvin it's been delight to have
you on star talk and i hope this is not
the last time uh we get you on i know
the
intergovernmental panel on climate
change comes out with these intermittent
reports and maybe we can reach back into
your office and get you back on star
talk but our fan base was delighted by
this so thank you for this yeah thank
you for having me and i'd be happy to
talk to you guys again all right all
right chuck always good to have you man
always a pleasure all right this is neil
degrasse tyson concluding yet another
episode of cosmic queries
climate change edition
as always i bid you to keep
[Music]